un juego de cartas usando 36 cartas
únicas cuatro para los diamantes
corazones tréboles y espadas con cartas
numeradas del 1 al 9 en dicho palo una
mano es una colección de nueve cartas
las cuales pueden ser ordenadas como los
jugadores lo elijan cuántas manos de
nueve cartas son posibles cuántas manos
de nueve cartas pueden ser posibles y
vamos a pensarlo son 36 cartas notas y
no nos preocuparemos pues como sabes son
9 números en cada palo y son 4 palos por
lo que son 4 por 9 son 36 pero pensemos
las cartas desde el 1 al 36 y vamos a
tomar 9 de ellas así que por aquí
tenemos 9 ranuras son 9 espacios y ahora
voy a tomar 4 cartas de mi mano y para
la primer ranura cuántas posibles cartas
puedo tomar y bueno son 36 cartas únicas
así que
la primer ranura serían 36 pero ahora
para la siguiente parte de cuántas
cartas tenemos para elegir ya habíamos
tomado una así que ahora tenemos 35 para
elegir y luego para el tercer espacio
serán 34 y así siguen adelante luego 33
32 31 hasta 28 entonces podrías decir
que son 36 por 35 por 34 por 33 por 32
por así hasta 28 posibles manos ahora
esto podría ser cierto si el orden nos
importará estos base verdad sí sí tal
vez bueno no voy a poner por aquí
digamos que tenemos quizás un 9 de
espadas aquí en un bonche de cartas y
tal vez tenga bueno eso es para una mano
y luego podemos decir que se sigue de 1
2 3 4 así sucesivamente hasta 8 o tal
vez tenemos otras cartas u otra mano de
cartas que vaya del 1 2 3 hasta el 8 y
al final tenga
nueve de espadas y si estamos pensando
estos dos como manos pues tienen
exactamente las mismas cartas pero en
diferente orden luego lo que yo calculé
hace mucho sentido porque las basamos en
orden pero nos están diciendo que las
cartas pueden ser ordenadas como el
jugador las elija por lo que el orden no
nos importa así que estamos contando
demás estamos contando todas las
diferentes formas de las cartas que
podemos organizar de tal forma que para
que no estemos contando demás tenemos
que dividir esto entre las formas en que
dichas cartas pueden organizarse por lo
que tenemos que dividir esto de tal
forma que las nueve cartas puedan
organizarse bien así que cree cuántas
formas puedo organizar las cartas tengo
nueve cartas y voy a tomar una de las
nueve en el primer espacio por lo que
tengo nueve formas de poner algo en ese
primer espacio luego tendría 8 y 7 6 5 4
2 y 1 este último espacio tendrá solo ya
una carta para ponerla ahí ahora este
número de aquí y esta multiplicación 9
por 8 por 7 y así y que empieza con 9 y
se multiplica por cada uno de sus
anteriores esto es llamado como un 9
factorial y se expresa con un signo de
admiración
así que si pensamos en todas las
diferentes posibles combinaciones de la
mano y estás este sería el número de
manos que estamos interesados pero luego
lo que queremos es dividir entre el
número de maneras que podemos ordenar
las cosas para que no estemos contando
de más y esta va a ser la respuesta va a
ser la respuesta correcta ahora bien
este número es súper súper largo y
déjeme figurarme qué tan grande es
tenemos 36 luego por 35 por 34 por 3 36
por aquí
por 35 por 34 por 33 y espero que la
calculadora realmente pueda realizar
esta operación y todo esto entre 9
factorial que sería entre 9 por 8 por 7
por 6 por 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
y lo que nos va a arrojar va a hacer
el siguiente número la respuesta son 94
millones 143 mil 280 y déjame poner esto
a un lado para poderlo leer bien y
entonces este número de aquí nos da 94
millones 143 mil doscientos ochenta así
que esta es la respuesta para este
problema son estas posibles manos de
nueve cartas en esta situación ahora
nosotros lo estamos razonando de esta
forma pero hay una fórmula para esto que
es esencialmente la misma cosa y la
forma en como la gente lo denota la
denota esta fórmula es diciendo bien
tenemos 36 cosas y algunas veces esto va
a ser escrito de esa forma que se dice
que tienes n cosas y se eligen acá pero
lo voy a escribir primero así y bien que
tenemos aquí tenemos 36 cosas de las
cuales elegiremos 9 por lo que este
número de aquí es el numerador va a ser
36 factorial
el cual tiene prácticamente todos los
números que van antes de él por ejemplo
el 27 26 25 y así sigue pero nosotros
paramos solo nueve formas de 36 entonces
esto es 36 autoridades por lo que esta
parte de aquí tenemos que este empecé
esta actualidad pero hay que dividirlo
entre 36 menos nueve factorial y cuánto
es 36 menos 9 son 27 así que aquí sería
27 factorial y vamos a pensarlo como que
el 36 factorial lo podemos extender de
esta forma para que más adelante lo
podamos cancelar con lo que tenemos en
la parte de abajo 36 factorial se
escribe de esta forma ahora cuando
tenemos esto sobre 27 factorial se va a
ver al desarrollar el 27 factorial como
27 por 26 por 25 así hasta 1 así que
aquí ya podemos cancelar esta parte
y pues son lo mismo entonces si divides
36 entre 36 menos 9 factorial obtienes
el primer término largo del 36 factorial
que es exactamente lo que tenemos por
aquí y luego lo dividimos entre 9
factorial que es entre 9 factorial y
esto de aquí es llamado como
combinaciones donde elegimos cada
elementos de n y algunas veces vas a
haberlo escrito la fórmula así de n en k
n inca que es una combinación o bien
como benefactoras sobre n menos casa
autoridad por k factorial donde tienes n
cosas y quieres encontrar todas las
posibles formas de las que puedas elegir
solamente acá y me importa el orden
únicamente te importa elegir qué cosas
de las n que tienes y hasta aquí está